hi there reject nation of Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch from
super mario logan at some l movie Jeffy
gets bullied we watched another one not
long ago Jeffy skipped school this is a
top reward to your video requests from a
lovely woman named Lonnie apparently her
two biggest passions are wrestling and
super mario Logan so let's check out one
of these other adventures of Jeffy
having to go to school
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you sure the student Jenny's crayons
or something to write this No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's right - at the same student well
my son said that bully does bully him I
know I have no choice
[Music]
Mario
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the whole time yeah Jeff in trouble no
Jeffrey no trouble now
born in trouble Charmin well Jeff I'm
glad the bully apologized but you
shouldn't beat up people should always
go tell a teacher or don't listen Melvin
cover yeah that's a great message so
shouldn't bully people and if you get
bullied you should stand up remember
Johnny Depp getting some really strong
advice from his mom bow when he was
getting bullied about taking a rock
hitting the guy with the rock that way
he doesn't antagonize you ever again
John I've had our experiences with
bullying I got an older brother you know
he doesn't bully me now just a major
control freak
I remember fourth grade I was my first
fight school fight ever one of like five
I've had we're playing two-hand touch
football
Thomas McDevitt oh who eventually became
one of my best friends for a short
period of my life it's all a few years
like a way later down the road we're
playing to hunt touch football he was
one of top jobs in school I tagged him
and he heating up he pushed me hard to
the ground I've been doing Taekwondo for
a couple years at this point but I still
never really I never stood up to him and
then when he pushing the ground just
snapped and I just started kicking it
really Oh like a roundhouse kicking him
a lot on the side grabbing through him
everyone was cheering for me because
someone took a stand against Thomas and
then later on he tried hitting me again
and I blocked it and everyone just
laughed he liked her swinging and
hitting me and I was like haha training
yeah yeah yeah it was still a tough
intimidating guy for many many years you
probably you know made him tougher in
doing that because I got a bully flood
of me on my turf you know what I love
about this whole concept is that the
teacher mainly the teacher shown
definitely I love a good racist
character Miz Mario and Peach super
trouble job the guy said to me like
Mario peach settling down they have a
kid peach wasn't really no so it kind of
just became super complete for me to see
both Mario and Peach is struggling with
their child
nothing like that because everything
else is so ridiculous and so heightened
to watch them both be like well I don't
know if he's actually getting bullied
you know like we like actually having
kind of a fuzzy dialogue back in what to
do about their son in juxtaposition to
everything else yet kind of did start to
tickle me increasingly as it went on
because compared to everyone else
they're the two most normal characters
yeah I really like this one because
Jeffy is wronged here I mean yeah the
best that is he doesn't worry abrasive
cat but you know what that's pretty
crappy what bully was doing to him bully
was really being abusive to him and so
yeah he taught him a lesson you know I
honestly I wish I was a little bit more
like Jeffy in certain ways when I was
younger just anytime I've been bullied
just to stand up for myself fight
instead of taking a timid approach you
know I've stood up a few times but I can
also recall many times where I just took
it there's a bullying epidemic than
bullying epidemics
decades forever I believe each other as
social and learning the fine line of
when to walk away
and when to not engage and when to stand
up for yourself is a tough thing but I
felt like Jeffy stood up for himself
let's face it he's not getting anywhere
in school so he might as well think it's
there it's inspiring to see him have
just no trouble taking a stand at all
because each time all three he stepped
up to the plate and was like I'm not
gonna take this from you I love the
[ __ ] about you know like third time's a
charm for an ass-whooping or whatever he
said and and sure enough he feels like
it's a third time I learned was third
time you know I mean the kid the camera
certainly huh and I do I guess
appreciate the way that the teacher is
just so gung-ho for like once they
finally see the circumstances he's like
oh yeah no you totally was in the right
to kick that ball really funny sketch I
appreciated that as heavily thanks
Lynnae thank you so much my dear I know
a couple weeks ago I said that we would
have that p.o box set up it's one of
those things they'll probably take a
half hour of our day it's just actually
hard to do it seems like because we've
never done it that it's an up it's a
it's a challenge that we have to carve
out so much time make sure we do it and
I'm sure the day when we actually do it
Lynnae it'll be like oh well I got back
under an hour next year p.o box coming
soon you've introduced this to a lot of
the name a lot of wrestling you've
educated us in the world of that so much
and now we're getting educated into the
expansion of the Super Mario universe oh
yeah so now movies really appreciate it
guys if you haven't subscribed to super
mario Logan make sure to do that right
away you guys can subscribe but the real
rejects please click that notification
bell if you want to get notified
whenever we got a youtube video up you
can check us on patreon we do weekly Q&A
TV show reaction stream along sync up or
there's the other option where many of
the shows have reaction highlights
included so you don't have to worry
about syncing up at all and he does
music video coverage weekly see you guys
you